ragazzi questo video che state per
vedere un video più per me che per voi
ma che ma chi siete voi
quando ero piccolo giocavo alla
playstation vabbè io ho iniziato a
giocare a che stava ancora nella pancia
di mia madre controller wireless per
ovvi motivi fisici uno dei primissimi
giochi della mia infanzia è stato rai
man 3 che secondo me è uno dei giochi
più sottovalutati della storia non so
per quale cacchio di motivo non so se
qualcuno di voi che stavano questo video
giocava rai mentre spero di sì vi prego
non voglio che qualcuno di capisca a
cena in tropez certo c'era anche le
cinematiche tratto incredibili sarà
nostri cinema tico tico no magari questa
nomea ricordo giuro
strano che appena la vedo sicuramente
una ricordo però adesso no
questi ragazzi sono in loop praticamente
sono delle fatine che se tu l'hai
prenditi ti rigenera un po la vita se
abbiamo colpito questo è il magico mondo
di rayman debito si sincera i meno bordo
rayman lavora che ricordi il coso verde
non mi ricordo il nome è il mio
personaggio preferito
ok lui è il cattivo del gioco 32 di
fermare lui perché vi fa fuori tutti i
numerosi lida formi lum neri bellissimo
se devi passare tutto il gioco a
catturare questo per dire a eco driver
globo siglato severa globo se quello di
fianco reimer è quello più piccolo il
globo se è ciccio nissimo ed è veramente
stupido la donna signori che entro è
questa era la mia infanzia prego prego
meraviglio benvenuti benvenuti nella mia
cervello ok spetta fare un ricordo più e
che gli hanno fatto doppiare la rocca
testo bene dai ragazzi con prandelli ma
ce la faccio a dio troppi ricordi loro
sentite le cagate che dice quell'altro
le incredibili ma dal tratto ragazzi il
bello è che me le ricordo ste franchi
per il disturbo a voi la preti tuo primo
lancio col paracadute senza paracadute è
perfetto ma teoricamente io posso fare
l'elicottero con i capelli c'è
praticamente io quando sull
eccolo infatti tu per planare poi parere
di coach era in maniera di un'ignoranza
abissale come gioco veramente allora
come la salsicciata tutto a posto
non mi ricordo i tasti qui dice che per
saltare
bisogna utilizzare il pulsante di salto
e beda
tutti gli altri che per attaccare
bisogna premere il pulsante vietato la
gara presa per il culo anche di giochi
del giorno d'oggi perché se pensate
quante volte nei giochi ti dicono per
saltare premi il tasto di salto grazie
al cup
cosa devo premer vi farà strano vedere
un gioco del genere perché con corona la
grafica incredibile a mamma mia cosa non
è i ragazzi ovvero piccolo le femmine
non esisteva esisterà questo criterio
dei capelli
ricordavo quelli sono troppo fa al look
e la casa anni fa non sto prendendo
tutti i libri punti perché chi se ne
frega però la cosa più assurda
il concilio delle fate bello se vuoi
cuccare che sconsiglio questo costo ma
perché no di vecchie megere un po cita
mai perdere il filo di saggezza del
manuale dice che gli interruttori
servono per attivare i meccanismi c'è
tra l'altro mi ricordo perfettamente non
so per quale motivo ma che cosa devo
fare me lo ricordo perfettamente in
tutte le cose che sto facendo
due giornate al mente tanto quando lo
piccolo che va beh voi aveste si vede
perché poi sono uscito con il 60 di blog
altro discorso di rai uno snap ha paura
perché tu puoi caricare il pugnetto e
tira una volta e mezza cartuccia quando
avrò trasformato l'energia del cuore non
tornerò ad occuparmi di te ma che
diavolo e questo perche trasforma i tuoi
abiti in tenuta da combattimento
praticamente questo ti dà un buon usato
ai combattimenti fare delle cose ci
serve incredi regione questo qua è bello
di tutti i colori ed e via questo può
essere perché la regione cose
bellissimo me lo ricordavo ed altro i
nemici che partissi delle consultazioni
che va dalla finezza di 20 napoli ai
zitto ditemelo sia esagerato è un
possibile madonna ragazzi è bello voi
non potete ogni ve lo giuro perché non
riesco a descriverlo quanto è quanto per
me è incredibile ct mi vedrete come un
deficiente questo ma vi assicuro che è
primo bellissimo per uno diceva tutti
sti anni passati vi deve passare chi ha
giocato di meno sei un fenomeno del sud
gas pro da bambino io veramente ragazzi
non so perché ma sono l'unica persona
della vita che se continua a giocare un
aroma in realtà non migliora quindi va
troppo forte e senza mari fatto
scherzando è ormai un fatto prodotto ero
posto ma non ho fatto niente non sta
facendo è sfruttata ma dopo il trattore
e due fantagenitori citata azienda ti
stai cercando sempre io in te io devo
back artifizio fin dalla fine del gioco
la donna se fossi in te mollerei qui e
andrà immediatamente a fare un provino
per spider man 2 cosa faresti un sacco
di soldi e nessuno ti prenderebbe più
per un coniglio non sa neanche come
commentare ste cagate ragazzi perché
sono ancora più stupide le cose che
direi io quindi per me lo fa lui lo sta
facendo lui commentari non possono dire
niente anyway adesso parte se non era
una roba incredibile che la transizione
da un mondo all'altro la fa meno così
ora la domanda che vi parla spontanea da
fare sarà ma che cosa fumano quelli che
fanno sito gioco che non lo so ragazzi
cosa fumata la ubisoft era veramente una
roba incredibile
devo stare un po la musica fermi tutti
perché è quella la parte importante in
questo momento vorrei campionare questa
musica e metterla nei miei video non c'è
un motivo perché non esiste motivo ma
c'è musica ovunque tutto il gioco è che
il musical mannaia sabbath e qua sembra
la cazzata ma vi assicuro veramente
difficile cioè che se il geometra dash
d'altri tempi proprio ok che altro che
porta knight mannaia
che il gioco un pazzesco regala sono
contento di averlo portato nel mio cioè
allora il mio canale ragazzi è una
specie di database di videogiochi
trovati ok negli ultimi otto anni e io
sono orgoglioso che questo faccia parte
della lista di giochi presenti il mio
canale orgoglio anche se lo questo video
anche solo per aver detto che l'ho
portato anche sul mio canale rayman o
chiamare non è facile pensare io tra
l'altro devo farmi tavo cinque anni nel
suo farlo adesso di figuriamoci preso a
questo è un salto incredibile
ok fatto sta mancando tutti i punti neri
prenderli tutti
cominciamo col hayden e questo era
veramente semplice ne sono alcuni che
sono impossibili ve lo dico io
eccolo perfetto perché ha aggiunto il
tema musica spero di loro territori
chiudi e fatica di qui a questi sono le
scarpe che queste scatole trovi i tic
siccome ha detto che ti danno i poteri
effettivamente sono questi ogni volta
che li liberi di con una frazione
casone guarda cosa oscar assegnato agli
utili grazie
devo andare a spegnere fare perché ogni
volta che gli ibridi con una cazzata
diversa morto con un fenomeno ragazzo
bravo ancora quando ma quando lui
quattro anni
questo il potere diverso questo è rosso
questo mi permette di spaccare le porte
e tirare dei pugni azzi e fanno un danno
pazzesco dal mio preferito
bene ma questi travestimento è stato
spettacoli e vabbè bellissima madonna
rai questi figli dei cartoni in faccia
che fanno malissimo poi danno
incredibile a tutti ci ora eccolo ce
n'era un altro la liberare ciao
[Musica]
pensavo fosse una cagata peggiore prova
ci sta yes bastone va bene così questo
allora mi fermo perché sono andiamo
avanti tutto il giorno per ora io per me
questo questo che avete visto vi ripeto
sto video più per me per voi questo e
rayman io da piccolo avevo un sacco di
giochi ai quali erano affezionato questo
fax bahr milos in time che comunque ho
già portato metal gear solid 1 e poi
tutti gli altri per all 1 è stato più in
questa è stata la mia infanzia che mi ha
portato poi a fare questo di lavoro
quindi è un po come se avessi voluto
rendere tributo a i giochi che mi hanno
formato
quindi grazie reimer grazie ubisoft
grazie a tutti quelli che hanno decorato
la mia infanzia
videoludicamente parlando di sky la gara
e le questa scia ad un prossimo video
bella ragazza
[Musica]